I see I spoke to a shaman once and he
said uh what makes you think that these
characters aren't real just because
you're playing them what makes you think
that they aren't they don't exist in the
space that you're you're portraying
you're putting them out and I was like
well because I could see myself he's
like you will you uh you maybe not
seeing the wholeness of who you are you
know I play Charles ever seen them in
that is interesting one because I just I
used to play football in high school and
in college for briefly for a year the
reason they didn't want to catch me was
cuz I was I just at that time lost a lot
of weight so I was like really thin you
know it was mostly from starvation from
not having any money you know and uh I
had to gain all this weight I gained
like 40 pounds to play that character
which normally would have been probably
my size anyway but it's like ironic that
that's what I had to do for that part
cuz I just seen I think we were it was a
shirt of the birth of a lot of guys like
myself as Sean Payton in the cage and
Ally Sheedy and a lot of us I mean Sean
was in character I remember one time him
and the guy who plays my brother like
standing behind me like discussing
stealing my bag
like they were go to this whole thing
about it and I like if I like let them
know that I that would be a mistake
think that's how I got to know him we
hadn't work together but we had a mutual
respect for like the way we work and
stuff and he spoke to me like later
about coming to do a film and he was
called bad boys but I was I I went back
to school and I didn't I felt that I
needed to learn some more about acting
so that's what I told him I need a
little bit longer before I get put in
the camera anymore I didn't feel like I
was good enough to be permanently put on
film for a feed for forever you I was
still learning and I I had been going to
a conservatory USC but then I switched
to the Drama Studio London conservatory
so I would they're just try to
understand my craft
understand about transformation and
stuff about how a lot of things that I
was still working on so I did I wasn't
ready
I didn't like my work
there enough finished out and I came
back and start working at the Mark Taper
Forum and enacted an improv group there
it was a long time I had like really my
own reasons for like acting were kind of
interested in revealing like sort of the
connection between people like pulling
away like experiences and trying to
understand what each character you know
where he connected to me and then
hopefully connects to everyone so that
was like my my journey my internal
journey my my my um my purpose around it
so it took a long time for me to be able
to feel like I could do that so I was
deep into my career I mean really deep
into my career before I felt like okay
this is what I should do for sure you
know I mean that the guy had already
wanted cons you know and even years
after that I still was like doubting
whether I had to capacity to be able to
play the character and I was trying to
figure out how to do something that
people were telling me I couldn't do I
was trying to figure how you can
disappear into the character transform
so greatly that it's another person in a
way actually I spoke to a shaman once
and he said what makes you think that
these characters aren't real just
because you're playing them what makes
you think that they aren't they don't
exist in the space that you're you're
portraying you're putting them out and I
was like well because I can see myself
he's like you will you uh you maybe not
seen the wholeness of who you are you
know but then it worked for me yes -
took me years and years and years and
years and years to finally really
probably I learned something from number
characters but probably last king like
help me understand something now I
didn't understand before but it's weird
because you can't necessarily repeat it
I couldn't necessarily make I couldn't
like I didn't find a technique to make
me be able to do it all the time it was
always a new discovery every time I
started a different part a whole new
process that I would have to find
the Last King of Scotland baby The Last
King of Scotland I played Idi Amin who
was a dictator in Uganda noted for
having done a number of atrocities I had
played Charlie Parker and burnt before
so I had played a real life character um
I think what it does is things that you
have to create like when you play a
regular character like you playing a
mechanic then you say okay you figure
out where he went to school you figure
out you know who how many people that
his family his relationship to this
community you know how he trained you
you get to do all that kind of study to
play the character but when you play in
a real character a lot of those love
things have been answered at least the
building blocks of being able to like
you know I know how old he was I know
when he became president I know what his
reputation was I interview people that
knew him interview people that talk to
him so there's a there's a spine that
you can at least lay the rest of your
work on you know you still have to do
all this other work but to really find
them but you at least have a spine I
didn't really think of him as a villain
so I mean I think that's what I'm
talking about you just like pull it away
the layers you pull away this experience
you know he was fighting with the mile
miles you pulled away this experience
the CIA tries to give him to be
president you pull away this experience
his mother like left him with his on you
know just keep pulling away till finally
at the end there's when they're all
experiences on the side that's just a
thing in the middle a light in the
middle that light in the middle is that
good thing that connects them to you
then you just put all this stuff back on
you put back all all the things back on
top of that then you have like a amount
but it's with cracked images crack lines
so the light kind of still shines
through so it's that light that shines
through that allows you to understand
how they connect to you and what you
could have done or what would happen if
you would have been in the same
circumstances in the same time on the
same certain situations and then you
learn a lot I think there's there's one
when when Nicholas James MacAvoy is
saying that he's gonna leave and I'm
like saying you know you can't you know
I don't remember the lines but I
remember you and I say to him something
like Uganda embraces you and I hug him
and he knows he can't leave
you can Uganda embraces you
I think there's there was something that
I worked on and there was something
about the madness that happened to when
everybody was attacking them because I
think the his fears of being attacked
and betrayed like fueled a lot of his
decisions as an ex-soldier there's a
scene where I'm lamenting I guess the
fact that I kicked out the Asian
something from the country and it was a
mistake and he should've helped you know
there was a mistake
and didn't so it's his fault
you know those interesting some
interesting scenes I did but you did not
must we'd meet new Colossus persuade me
there's number of them you know to be so
angry to be so much in pain as he was in
and then to have to torture his friend
to feel betrayed betrayal was a big deal
for him you know there were the eleven
factions around the country that were
trying to destroy him like different
armed groups so some of his paranoia was
true color of mind it's interesting
because that was a replacement I was
there we hired somebody else to play the
part and I had auditioned for the part
but I didn't get it and then um this
actor was like written is kind of a
white yuppie character and I guess he
didn't play pool I didn't actually but
but I had two weeks to get ready to do
it so I was in the pool wall like 14
hours a day just playing pool first
thing I got to Chicago I went to the
pool on a play I brought my own stick
and then the first thing that Martin
Scorsese made me do actually wasn't the
addition of the lines it was actually to
play pool so I played the nine ball
champion of the world for one for that
game what happened was the nine ball
champion was trying to convince Martin
Scorsese to do a ball too so
for me it was a good stroke of luck
because I got to go first and I got to
do a ball the balls fell pretty well so
almost won the game
yeah and uh then I missed him you can't
really miss a guy like that so how's
that hey you don't wanna pay me keep it
forget it I don't want no bad feelings
we got losses
I lost stuff hey you were hast ravished
what want to quit
oh how was a young kid um I wasn't
really dealt with like you know like as
a peer really you know in fact most of
the time I was in the back watching them
rehearse I didn't really even get into
the rehearsal process then I did to see
that it's um there was an opinion on the
scene and I can whatever you do but I
was pretty clear on the way the
character would behave so ultimately I I
did I did heroin ask you something what
you're honest with me I think I need to
lose some weight
[Music]
yeah it's a really interesting character
it's very simple it's one scene but uh I
say I think it's a pivotal scene for me
career-wise because uh I mean pauline
kael like wrote something about it
became like something than other
filmmakers like noticed and stuff
Charlie Parker that was the first time
like there's like some pivotal films for
me like for I considered like four films
that were pivotal for me that was one of
the first ones I think because Clint
Eastwood like trusted me to to play that
character I hadn't done nothing to
justify being able to play a role of
that magnitude so I was nervous and
afraid and it taught me a great deal
about like diving in through my fear I
always talked about it like dance down
on a limb you know where you know that
the limbs are gonna possibly break and
put you dance anyway then you realize
from doing the project that even if the
limbs break you won't break you too
silly your body you may break your arm
but you'll be okay
now project taught me a lot about beauty
character finding the character I had
like not merriment I didn't have very
much film footage only like any animals
15 second clip that's all there is of
Charlie Parker in video so I had his
books so I had like moved downtown
because I needed to be away from
everything move down into like more
where like some of the heroin addicts
worried stuff like that then I just put
like his pitches all over on the wrong
and loft and I took the sacks I haven't
got a sacks as soon as I thought I had
the part
turned out later that the sacks was
broken and I was wondering I was so hard
to [ __ ] out of it but it was good
because when I got a real sax it was
good sax then the sounds were like we
were able to flow out because I have
been practicing so hard trying to make a
good sound come out of nothing that was
the beginning of like trying to figure
out the character reading this stuff
talking to his wife you know trying to
understand what heroin addiction this
stuff was
don't help man don't help
don't you know Clint Eastwood directed
Burt I think he understands the acting
process he created situations that would
allow me to learn more like I think was
with a buddy Johnson was a sax player
that he like set up for me to meet me
settle for me to meet his wife and set
up those kinds of things that was
helping me figure out the character and
then you could say something really
simple like just hold your head up means
a lot at certain moments which money
just says something very simple but then
you do it and then he like changes your
whole attitude towards the face of the
scene yeah there's a couple of scenes in
it that strike me when that one is the
one when I die I had like been getting
ready for the part to that to do that
scene and I hadn't slept for days I came
to the scene at night I laid down on the
couch where I was going to do a shot and
I kind of fell asleep you know I mean
you know they were filming I fell asleep
because I was laying down and then I was
getting woken up and I look at this guy
he's got a smile on his face you know
because the guy he's playing the doctor
they seemed like I was like who are you
you know it's thick it was like really
uh I'll never forget that because then I
looked over and I realized oh there's
cameras here I was like oh I'm doing
this scene you know and what play was
like I was like I'm sorry clean I think
no yeah so then I got to do a chance to
do it again there's another scene I
think where my daughter dies and I had
to continually call I'm called calling
to like to talk to mow to tell my wife
to like you know you know I'm coming
home
I know the card on a diet that scene was
really just a series of the same calls
call over and over and over getting you
it's like a slow descent into
you know pain but that was that was seen
with it you see to the news of our
daughters that surprised me more than
they did you do not fulfill funeral
proceedings until I get there I shall be
the first one to walk you into the
chapel forgive me for not being in the
hospital with you I say is that the four
films that kind of like mark me marked
me for me I guess it probably would be
one of them would be burnt when we're
talking about probably a ghost talk
while asking a Scotland and actually the
butler I mean I'll give me different
things they all like taught me different
things ghosts on the way in the samurai
it was written for me yeah I'm a gym
super a parking lot and we decided we
wanted to work together and then like a
year or so later he called me and said
he had an idea so then we we just
started meeting and just talking about
philosophy different things that
wouldn't have four series of time to
come in and we hang out for like five or
six hours and then go back to New York
and then one day I said you know I'm
gonna write it they wrote the script
then in his mind at the time he said was
his representation of who I was I
thought was brilliant it's difficult
role it taught me like a saying like
different things teach you different
things taught me a lot about silence in
vibration you know because there were
scenes where I was you know just sitting
there driving like minutes at a time no
dialogue just camera sitting in front of
me and I had to figure out how to
vibrate well enough to like make the
audience hear my thoughts enough and
feel my energy enough to be compelled to
watch you know that long taught me a lot
about vibration silence like last king
taught me about transformation
transmutation
little different about shifting your
energy to such a degree that maybe you
can you can um can disappear I try to
think I try don't want to feel like I
could do that but every time it's always
something new every time the journey I
think I figured something out and then
it's like just as hard to get the
character the next time you know what
that is about but I mean there's always
something carried with you from a
character I'm not necessarily for the
next character but for you as a person
and of course you're bringing yourself
it's like little incarnate lives you
it's like you're reincarnated every all
the time and each time there's like a
little thing that's left from a life
before maybe it's the way you say a word
or I'm swayed you gesture maybe the way
you react to a certain thing your
awareness about it just informs you
differently you know there's so many
season that movie yet I like the kind of
Frankenstein reference I like the with a
little girl you know when I'm reading
the book and stuff I think the stuff
with Isaac with the ball clay he's the
ice cream vendor he's uh it's really
unique you know two people having a
conversation they don't understand each
other but they completely understand
each other I think that's something
brilliant on a Jim's mind be Daniels but
I auditioned for the part in the prism
if I the part it's something I really
wanted to and if they would eat that for
me if they liked everyone I'd when I did
last King auditioned I understood the
director was having you know wasn't sure
he hadn't seen me do anything like that
and he wasn't sure if I would be able to
pull it off so I understood you know I
don't know as far as the butler I don't
remember what these question was about
that one but I did audition with with
Oprah with him and then they just moved
forward right there it taught me a lot
about transit it's you know this at the
time I was like sometimes just feel like
I was in a sea of blue like everything
was just moving perfectly I didn't have
to do anything sometimes like I don't
know what it was anybody taught me that
space which I I I grew trust in when I
was doing the project I mean I didn't
necessarily have it on this TV show I'm
not sure but I did then it was one of
the first times I've ever felt that way
where everything was like moving on its
own everything was working it seemed
where I go and I explained to the person
in the white house that I need to get a
raise and I've spoken to the president
and I'm standing up for my rights at
that point I'm gonna have to be paid to
say as a white Hill or I might have to
move OH
I guess you'll be moving on then I think
I'm like maybe 90 something in that
scene you know because that was the
thing about the it was a great challenge
for me this is des stuck
I learned up I have implied it I guess
but I learned a process of how to age in
this film that really really really was
something I had never done before it was
like figuring out different parts of my
body to move from certain parts where I
could put pains in my body from
emotional memories and stuff that would
affect me inside the scene it was very
technical in some ways I think but then
it led to like just sort of trans I had
stayed up I was talking about
I don't present did you say that you
don't need to tell you to take this up
on him
I broke the script down like to like
what I call hot points
you know the body and stuff I did that
on my own and then where you moved from
at different ages and that affected me
that was back in some ways it was giving
a great experience but it affected like
my body like later even now to this day
I think it affects it affected me yeah I
can feel it I should you know whenever
it was I did that convinced myself that
that's what I needed to do I don't
remember what it was somewhere in my
DNA's in a way but um that's what I did
wrong one
yes you know Star Wars since I was in
high school I thought it was great you
know I mean uh it's um it's great
character I love Star Wars and I like
science fiction anyway that was a great
one it was an amazing role because it
was like one of the if not the first one
of the first kind of great characters in
the trilogy in the history of you know
the show he was created by by by Lucas I
think as a particular standalone
character saw Guerrera he was like a
revolutionary and you see that he's the
characters who's fighting for good but
like his torturing people and that's
that he lives in a gray area or what he
thinks by any means necessary you know
in order for us to win and I think that
was really unique character to get to
play in the Star Wars history usually
it's like good or bad either gonna be
the Vader you're gonna be hit the you
guys like as opposed to like always in
the middle where I will torture you if
you know in order to get the information
I need to save the universe you're
trying to save the universe from the
Ducks you know and you would do whatever
it took to do so and that's that is an
unusual attitude towards character in
Star Wars poor gullet will know the
truth
unfortunate side effect is that one
tends to use one's mine yeah Oh when I
first went there I walked on the set and
it was was a battlefield then there was
like a bunch of clothes that were you
know we're dead on the ground and stuff
troopers you know it felt like a war
zone
no it's like unusual to me because when
you watch think of Star Wars you don't
think of blood because they don't really
you don't seen it but this director was
pushing it towards that were to feel
like war so when I went to my domain it
was all practical sets except for like a
window but everything else was like
built built so I was tangible for me I
could touch it except for like if I was
looking at a 3d object or something like
that
in arrival I play I think it was a
colonel who was tasked with like
communicating with these alien beings
and brought in a team to be able to do
so no it was interesting because I was
playing on strength I mean as a look as
a leader as an academic military man
that was kinda interesting to play I
played a number of military characters
before down he was a little different
you know I think I regionalised about
think he came from the east coast yeah
I'm pretty sure he's more of a Boston
accent
always trying to figure out where you're
coming from and stuff does it mean that
you changed you have an accident just
means it you know cuz everybody from
different places don't have accidents
anyway but it's a it just helps you
figure out what the heck you're doing
you know how you would respond but if I
tell you them from Baltimore or from
Boston and mechanic immediately you like
start to like simulate like a bunch of
thoughts around it it's not like yeah
now you had what do you make of it
is that yes Amy Adams was amazing to
work with she's really talented actress
you know she's really amazing I thought
she was really committed to the scenes
and stuff like that and just kind of was
pushing herself to do some great work
and some of the work wasn't easy you
know because we were always CG stuff
that you have to like imagine in front
of you I think that they did some kind
of because we could we'd they gave us a
big screen and there was something
moving behind it that we could look at
and I remember I think that any drawings
they had something but I mean the
reality of it didn't happen until till
later I think he was I think he was
figuring all that out we were in like
what do you call those hazmat suits
whitter yeah and it was it was easy to
react to it because it's like I guess a
it was like big giant like almost full
screen and behind it was like little
puppets or silhouettes moving around so
you know I think as a military guy at
that point I wasn't looking at it in any
kind of state of fear I was I wasn't
going to exercise and communication that
was what we were there for I think the
movie tries to deal with this issue of
communication
[Music]
I play Jody yeah I don't remember I had
a last name I mean I must have better
remember it Jody is a soldier he was a
soldier in the British Army and he like
falls in love with Jay Davidson's
character who turns out to be a
transgender spot there that that
characters relationship with this Irish
man who is with the IRA and how he
commences this man to go back in to see
his love
once he dies I won't say kill him it was
always important to Neil Jordan I
thought the new Jordan remember we were
at cons and I was there for some reason
and you can't what to talk to me about
doing the project and uh that that was
really important because I think there
were times when people tried to convince
him to make it a female character and
but that wasn't gonna happen
you know I knew that from the beginning
so it was not an easy project to get
made crying game like was took them
years to raise the money and even when
they dig it the money was hardly
anything probably like a couple million
bucks and uh they didn't have the money
really I just said that because I got I
got there and like they weren't able to
do any of the things that they were
supposed to be able to do as far as
giving you a car and this is not you
know and then finally Steve wildy told
me like I'm sorry but I'm gonna having
to go to my theater everyday and get the
receipts to come back and run the next
day for shooting that's kind of how it
happened because we did have
Miramax wasn't involved how everyone
seen wasn't involved until after it was
done so in order for him to make it we
all have to make a lot of compromises I
didn't work that lonely but I worked
like two weeks I think I prepped
prepared for the part probably longer
than I actually shot the part
- he's one of the members of the
Infantry's african-american you know
it's key important it's because the
unit's the way they were put up together
and stuff like that they call ever
Oliver ended up doing a scene you didn't
have a scene it was a scene out I said
to him we need to have a scene where the
where the black brothers come together -
because you know how they populated the
MPhil tree the infantry that that time a
period was populated greatly by
minorities I think the highest minority
per capita would be the natives the
Native Americans were the highest per
capita and so asked him did I and he
wrote it you about to see it's a small
scene but it's there so that's cool and
then platoon is an exercise in like
forced method acting you know we were
brought off of a plane we're just kids
we were given a shovel told to dig dig a
hole and then minused and you said these
are your clothes this is where you're
gonna be sleeping this hold is where
you're gonna be sleeping for the next
two weeks you know what I mean and
you're gonna be sleep-deprived because
they need privacy
two hours up two hours down and sleep -
rats a day water period we get lost in
the jungle he learned a lot you know I
wasn't really silly guys so what guys
was more pissed you learned how to do
simple things like what happens when
you're in maneuvers and your guns
jamming so in the film you a lot of
times where people's guns Jim you just
automatically start cleaning it out
stuff that you wouldn't normally have
done how do you take your food what you
would eat you know what you would
discard you know like what you would
trade with the guy next to you it's how
to sleep you know like you start to
realize like that you can sleep on top
of a rock if you're tired you're tired
and you go to sleep you know I mean and
stuck that I worried that the hole is
full of ants because you know that if
you get in there answer leave so it's
like you start learning all these things
about about being in the military or
being in jungle warfare we would get
lost for days you know there would be
attacked by the by the Filipino Marines
those was an exercise but you brought a
lot of first peoples internal
personalities outward you know
during that process the Godfather's
father finally got for the halt of my
play a Papa John's who is the crime lord
of the Godfather that runs the Mafia
in Harlem and he was connected to the
five families did you know busy family
there's some amazing artists involved
first of all I think all the actors in
the shore like amazing all of them you
know new ones - like your financial
course she's my wife and an Internet
legacy she plays my daughter she's
they're amazing
Benton's monstrous is uh edited chin and
tell Carla Zito is like just
insurmountable and then you had the
Mafia families you know Chad's
commentary and Paul Sorvino so it's it's
like an amazing grouping I'm not even
saying them all artists who like her
making this amazing film I think that
the scripts themselves are really
powerful really well-written and I was
fortunate because I started on this from
idea so I've been involved with it's
just the idea and then we moved in we
got writers and Christian Paul created
scratch or something I think it's really
great became as producers and
showrunners and so for me it's been
exciting just to see to bring this
project from idea to creation you know
in for it to be as powerful as I hoped
it would be
I love the piece so much has changed in
Harlem since you've been gone
I just knew you'll get right back into
this or any things you already back into
sweetie things
this is bumpy Johnson he's alleged he
took on Dutch Schultz back in the day
I'm putting things back to where they
were times have changed I haven't I
guess mafia stuff is always interesting
but I think the whole question of like
falling from darkness into light you
know like what happens with bumpy
Johnson is that the education about me
Johnson does he like understand like
because he's a guy who like his old
crime lord but also but also was trying
to uplift his community so what happens
when a heroin dealer has to like deal
with this prostitute heroin addicted
daughter on the streets and how he
resolves that and what that says to us
and I think it was important for us to
bring the message enough today into the
piece so a lot of stuff about the opiate
crisis and the polarization of the
country the immigration issues all these
things are inside of the true story of
what happened in 1963 and they reflected
for people to look as a mirror for
what's happening today I think even like
the civil rights movement that's going
on inside the piece because deals a lot
with his movement with Malcolm X in his
friendship with him we can see like
these protests and marches and things
popping their heads up coming out in our
state today and hopefully they'll
continue to people will continue to
protest for human rights and I think the
show talks a little bit about that well
it's unbelievably entertaining it's
great because I get to look at all the
avenues and the character and expand I
know the family in this project is
really important and I wouldn't get to
explore how the depth of that family
like I'm going to be able to as we go
through it over the next number of years
it's a political structure like him like
dealing with civil rights movement and I
wouldn't get to explore but this this
way I have a really broad stroking brush
to be able to create like a fully
actualized character and at all points
be complex
then looking at the next complexity